welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss i'm here with
mt mastertainment and we are going to
do a fun pre-season q a for the falcon
winter soldier we're taking questions
from our listeners on stereo if you
don't have stereo
be sure to go to stereo.com rockstars
and download the free stereo app
uh and we will be taking questions uh
we're currently simulcasting this on
the time we recorded our first episode
of this
so let's go ahead and take a question
here the bevels
on zemo's mask look like daddy dan dan's
chin like that
a little little way for zemo to remind
the
but then like you know everything
snapped and he lost like five years of
his life and
he got even more pissed off with that
for some reason i didn't even think
about that i thought you were joking at
first that's actually a really cool
theory
um i'm sorry you want to repeat that
because i was so focused on daddy fan
fanboy
that you call him daddyfantan you get
points for that
right off the bat right away but
what an interesting tactic right an
intimidation tactic
attack tack i'm now talking like
david what's a wonderful attack tag
the uh the idea of recognizing that the
world is traumatized by this
purple eternal deviant that came from
another world
to devastate the universe and now using
that color purple as like almost a
tribal
fear tactic brilliant if so if that was
intentional i don't know if the
the bevels the ridges because the ridges
are so specific i don't know if the
world when
they see all ridges and things are like
triggered by thanos you know
but just the idea phobia i can't do
ridges
in tandem though of specifically a
purple mask
with these ridges of just like uh the
world feared a purple skin
villain i'm gonna give him that color
now uh i could totally see
zemo going by that rationale i think
that's really cool i really love that i
really love that theory i think it'd be
really cool to see
zemo um and like influenced by thanos in
a way and just be like
all right he broke the avengers sort of
and i like doing that so
let me wear his face because that's my
hero thanos
the man um but yeah that's a really good
theory i really like that one
that's right i do too daddy fan fan
that's gonna be in my brain for the rest
of my life
hey you did it eric i like it all right
do you guys
think that zemo is gonna team up with
falcon winter soldier
to take down any other super soldiers
that is a fantastic question
that is a good question what do you
think about that mt i mean possibly i
mean i think that zemo is
one to use people as tools and stuff so
like
you know it is possible we have those
super soldiers that were in those tanks
in civil war
that zemo killed um but there could be
others
potentially i mean that could just be
one site
yeah absolutely based off of what we've
seen in the trailers it seems like he
has
a group of differently dressed henchmen
at least in that uh the scene the
footage where he's like blowing up
something in the shipping yard
and it's like you don't have differently
dressed henchmen if it's not like a
group of super soldiers
so that's why i'm thinking we could be
seeing some kind of thunderbolts-esque
plot i'm not saying we're gonna see the
thunderbolts in the falcon winter
soldier but something inspired by that
what is zemo's plan i think his plan is
to rid the world of super
uh heroes but in order to do that he
needs to kind of assemble his
own pseudo-avengers team i think that's
what he discovered was his mistake
is he was working alone in civil war and
he's like okay well if i want to
continue this mission what do i need i
need my own
team uh and that's what the avengers had
that i didn't
and he maybe made the mistake of
plugging all of those uh winter soldiers
when he's like maybe i could have used
them
a little bit he would
yeah i mean i could have just left them
in the fridge for a little bit more just
in case i needed them who knows
yeah but yeah no he uh he definitely
iced those guys too fast so maybe
there's more
who knows yeah and that's why i think
when we watch this uh this trailer
that we reacted to of uh you know there
are wizards there are androids there are
aliens they're facing some other kind of
super powered threat
going forward and uh we don't know
exactly what that
is uh why do why does he need to
categorize them if it's just the flag
smashers the flag smashers don't appear
to have
any supernatural powers unless they do
and in which case
where do they get those powers how do
they get those powers is it
technological based
is it sorcery based are they aliens i'm
guessing not aliens we you know
uh or maybe they are but you know we
have plenty of scrolls
already yeah i don't need more aliens
right now um
or is it a fourth category is it mutants
and that's what we're starting to see
rise in the mcu is zemo's identifying
damn now there are even more
superheroes around the world i need to
get to the point to where society views
all of them as a threat so i'm going to
turn them into these villainous kind of
figures i'm going to take out the
remaining adventures that are left
uh and i'm gonna make all superheroes
into pariahs
that's my that's my plan uh wanda's
really helping him out with uh
making heroes look really bad so you
know thanks wanda um
no that but no seriously uh that could
yeah that could easily be a thing in
terms of all that but before i continue
losing your hair can be a bummer life is
hard enough waiting for that ever
elusive first eternals trailer without
also having to worry about hair loss two
out of three guys will experience some
form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35 and i know a lot of guys
in my life that are super stressed out
about it but with keeps it is easier and
more affordable to get treatment for
your hair loss
and help you keep the hair that you have
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy you used to have to go to
a doctor's office for this kind of
treatment but with keeps you can do it
all from home
you meet a doctor online and they ship
the treatment right to you every three
months so you don't have to wait in line
at the pharmacy
find out why keep says more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly 100 000 men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medication if
you're noticing that you're losing your
hair
do something about it for a limited time
go to keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order should we take
another question yeah go ahead if you
want to hit uh the next question there
hey eric hey mt uh these flag smashers
these people that are just trying to
bring john lennon's imagine to reality
could be enhanced with some sort of
super soldier serum
uh possibly the red vials that we saw in
the black widow trailer
oh that's an interesting theory i love
that idea that is a
very good point yeah that's a whole
other alternate angle of this rather
than being mutants maybe there's a
limited number of these people
and they have those yeah those red vials
is kind of a mystery right
you know black widow has been delayed so
much i keep like forgetting those loose
and theory threads that i was so excited
to see resolved
you know may 2020. yeah but those red
vials i've speculated those could be
pinned particles
probably not pin particles i'm willing
to admit that but
yeah they're they're something right and
they're tied to the red
room and the red room uh has this kind
of br
mind control brainwashing that they do
to kind of turn them
into soldiers as far as we know uh black
widows
black widow assassins don't have super
powered abilities
but you know uh natasha romanov is a
badass she's a great fighter
um but it doesn't seem like she has
strength she just kind of has like
more agility than the average human
fighter does
uh so i would be very surprised if it
was super soldier serum because
uh but but we do have red guardian you
know red guardian was enhanced with some
other kind of cocktail
so maybe that is that's what enhanced
red guardian but not necessarily the red
room
uh to tie that could be an interesting
crossover from black widow
uh for sure but uh it it would
mean that all these people that would
have to leak somewhere beyond
the limits of uh soviet russia unless
all those people were in the prison
with uh with red guardian those that's
what they were doing there
i mean like i i definitely think that uh
the super soul a super soldier serum
um attempt will be probably made in this
show
um because like that's a huge part of
the captain america mythos
and you know in the comics everyone's
trying to recreate this formula i mean
like
um what was his name um eric scene dr
irksyn yeah donna erskine
yeah yeah um in uh the first avenger
um you know he perfected that formula
and no one has been able to do it
so maybe these um flag smashers have a
variation of that formula
but isn't perfect so like maybe it's
making them be
extra radical and like extra violent and
like you know because the formula isn't
perfected
so like i definitely feel like i don't
know about the black widow piece
specifically because anything could have
been in those vials um yeah but
you know i definitely think that super
soldiers a super soldier's serum of
sorts
wow that was alliteration a super
soldier serum of sorts could be in play
wow i do love that theory a lot we'll be
keeping an eye on that hopefully
hopefully something comes out of that um
empty let's take another question from
stereo
let's do it hey guys i was wondering
what your thoughts were of wolverine
popping up as patch in the show
i personally don't think so but i would
love to hear your thoughts also
keep up with the great work love you
guys oh thank you so much
i love you too sir i'm a big fan of your
accent it's very nice i wish i had that
accent very nice
i just have this yeah i think wolverine
uh
pro it might be too soon to see like uh
um
like patch logan show up uh just because
i think kevin
feige's mutant plan he's gonna want to
go a restoration approach of like this
is how mutants should
be unfolded in a cinematic universe
and he's gonna make some cast some bold
casting changes
um maybe swap some you know uh like this
character's male now they're gonna be
female
this character was originally this that
was a little problematic so we're gonna
change this
to make it more appealing to audiences
you might see some of that but other
than that i feel like it's gonna be
classic because it already works
overall like starting magneto and
auschwitz is such an amazing character
origin don't change that please you know
so uh if they're going to do that at
first we might see patch logan at some
point in the future
uh i just think it might be a little too
soon it might be a little too confusing
to audiences who
don't know the comics as well and once
we see wolverine i think it's going to
be a fairly classic approach
to uh to the logan mythology in the mcu
and
it might be a little too soon to have a
character with the you know with the dog
tax
or in this case with an eye patch
version of him uh
maybe just a little too soon for me yeah
no i i completely agree i honestly think
that
in terms of mutants and coming into the
mcu i have this weird feeling that kevin
feige might want to wait
until um you know a theater-based
film that everyone can see like right
regardless of whether or not you have
disney plus
because ninja plus is like you know you
could have you could not have it
so like not in every country yeah
exactly so like i think when mutants
come it's going to be like
everyone knows at the same exact time
that mutants are here
so i think that where any mutant or
wolverine type stuff is going to have to
happen
after um that the the whole world is on
the same page that mutants
are here um yeah so i i don't think that
they'll be showing up in this series
yeah let's take another question let's
do it
eric call your shot right now what
theory are you going to beat the drum
for
for weeks and weeks and weeks only for
it not to come true
for falcon winter soldier what is the
falcon winter soldier equivalent of
mephisto
booyah that sounds like off-screen
producer zach cuddleston
a little bit uh yeah so in this
in the longer version of this that that
came out on friday
uh i think mt and i decided that we will
be on the zola train
for now until
we're going to be looking on every
background screen in this show if it
looks a little green
you know it was red in one division it's
going to be the color green in this show
be like i saw some green matrix c code
on that and that looked like the face of
toby jones on that screen
it's like i saw zola in the grass i saw
him in the grass that grassroots
join us on the zola train world
it's so comfy on the zola levitt one
with zola
we have nice swiss chocolate on the
train
uh oh it's so great you know um
you all get swatches amazing swatches um
all right new question if someone wants
to get started by reading some of the
marvel comics
for falcon and the winter soldier what
are
at least like three or five you suggest
to get prepared for the series
i mean obviously when um falcon takes
over the role as captain america i mean
like falcon cap comics
amazing first of all you should
definitely read them um they definitely
uh they they touch on isaiah bradley i
believe they they should
yeah and i mean the the whole like
uh early 2000s ultimates winter soldier
series when they brought back bucky i
mean it
really inspired the winter soldier arc
in in the winter soldier movie
but like there is so much truth to the
character in his history that i think
everyone should read and everyone should
know i i can't recommend that enough it
was so great
um the way they brought back bucky was
was crazy
i mean the thunderbolts is pretty great
just to get a sense of zemo
and like what zemo's operation will be
like when they bring back uh
like that whole arc of his whole
thunderbolts arc
uh when was that that was 90s right i
don't know the year on that one
thunderbolts i think that might be two
thousands yeah
one division we had a uh a sense of like
oh yeah read house of m
because there was like there's only so
many
uh scarlet witch comics that have
actually really been great
um there's been they've made appearances
uh over the years
but like we had a sense of one division
we had a sense of west coast avengers
from 89
we uh got a sense of uh uh what are some
other ones that they talked about
over the tom king vision but like and
then at the end
you just hear jack schaefer in an
interview saying i don't really get
comics i think they look pretty
so i use some of the visuals but they
don't really inspire me that much
and then it's like well you know okay
understand your audience maybe a little
bit
you're a great writer you made something
great but clearly these writers are
taken from other influences
that's what say someone like malcolm
spellman he definitely grew up with the
comics
um but like i think he's going to be
inspired by
other themes and other issues than just
staying faithful and true to a specific
comic run that part is the reason it's
so exciting to watch this because
we don't really have a specific road map
of this is what the plot story beats are
going to be
yeah completely like it's it's the
unexpected like we shouldn't
know what's going to happen like i don't
want to read like you know
past falcon stuff pass bucky stuff pass
zemo stuff and be like
this is a lot like what's already been
done like just show me something new
something fresh and like
kevin feige in the mcu is they have a
track record of just showing us things
that we didn't know that we wanted
so yeah i i definitely agree so
i i it is harder for this series to to
to find a
specific run because captain america has
been around and like all those
characters have been around for forever
for a while like you know yeah so like
i would i personally would recommend um
you know that when
cab sam gets the shield like th that
initial run when he's captain america
is just a really fun run and i'm sure
that they'll obviously be taking a lot
of inspiration from
for the series let's take a let's take
another question
do you think the john walker captain
america government picked guy
is going to have a um new vibranium
shield or do you think it's going to be
maybe a shield man of some other
substance or what do you think i think
the shield at the end of end game
is gonna go to him and he's not gonna
know how to use it properly he's just
gonna use it as a prop
uh and then the whole time everyone's
gonna have shield envy and
part of this mission is like getting
that shield away from him
uh because he's doing bad things with it
um i don't think we're gonna have
multiple shields
uh unless he's just having a prop shield
for like publicity events
and there's another shield but i think
he's gonna go on missions he's gonna do
stuff and he's probably gonna kill
people and people can be like holy [ __ ]
like he kills like people and we said he
doesn't need to like stop he's already
dead
john yeah i i think that's the shield i
think he's gonna get
a cap shield from the end of end game
and
it was it's considered government
property it belongs at a museum
and it's going to be taken and given to
him and sam's going to be like ugh
fine i mean i'm falcon but that guy
doesn't deserve the shield and that's
going to be kind of the the
part of the problem here no i completely
agree i mean the whole show is about
this the legacy of captain america and
the legacy of the shield and so
having multiple shields would kind of
just like be kind of a shield
distraction
of sorts so i definitely think that
you're you're right on the money it's
just like one shield
everyone's struggling for the shield sam
wants a shield walker wants a shield
bucky might be a little bit jealous he
doesn't have the shield but like that's
okay
um but yeah it's it's yeah i think it's
just gonna be a one shield type deal and
um
uh walker won't have it for long i mean
they'll have it for a little bit i feel
but like then
sam will you won't get back because yeah
that's his shield
yeah all right good question i really
like that question we have time for a
few more questions
so let's just take another one what do
you guys want to happen not like what
you guys think is gonna happen in series
what do you guys want to happen the most
that is a really great question
um i personally and this is something
i've been actively thinking about
i want sam to have his bird
powers i want him to be able to talk to
birds
or specifically red i want red wing the
real bird
i think that'd just be really really
cool for him to have red wing
um and uh you know with i don't know
like if if people do have powers or
people
are starting to get powers or people are
experimenting with
um giving people powers potentially um
maybe maybe uh we could have some weird
bird stuff with uh
santa who knows how about you erica what
do you want
oh sky's the limit okay here's my wish
list for the falcon winter soldier
um i want the i want
isaiah bradley to come up in this and i
want the whole history of black captain
america i want him
and his descendants to get the shield so
i want the shield to eventually go to
elijah bradley patriot and that's why i
want to have the shield at the end of
the series
i want bucky to continue to be the
winter soldier i want falcon to continue
to be
falcon and we just love falcon for that
uh but like the the spiritual legacy
of who cap was to the mcu is uh
is you know falcon essentially uh i want
old cap to die
but i want young chris evans to show up
from an alternate timeline to kind of
give us some answers
and i want an implication that he was
friends with wolverine in that alternate
timeline and that bucky got to be
i got to carry the shield in that
history i want
them to go to madrid and go to a bar and
see logan
was here carved into the bar and uh
um a ninja to do a backflip in the
background a hand ninja to be
to do a backflip in the background and
then the mandarin uh to kind of uh show
up
with a limousine lowered in the mandarin
space behind it tony leon from shangchi
uh what else what else what else can i
do okay i want the implication
of uh other mutants to start to exist in
this world and people are confused by
what that is but then we start to get
some speculation that
oh maybe the return of the blip and uh
something related that started to awaken
an evolutionary step and people had this
mutant gene for generations
now starting to arise and then just a
hint towards the eternals that maybe the
celestials gave certain
members of humankind an ex-gene and
that's why and we haven't needed it
until now
uh and i want a battle with an android
version of zola
at some point
you know what i changed my answer to
that last one i want robozola
so badly it's it'd be so funny like
funny looking but i know
kevin fein you could pull it off to make
it look cool
so no yes robozola only only robots
um all right let's do it my first
question
is have you guys seen any pre-screenings
of the show
um not as of yet um we got a little
lucky with one division
in that we knew a guy who knew a guy who
knew like disney publicity
who was able to get us those uh i think
the first you know it's the first three
episodes we were able to watch so we
were able to get them ahead of time
do some breakdowns ahead of time uh get
that written it
honestly we don't release stuff uh and
we don't leak anything
until after everyone can see it so
really it just changes
how fast i have to work on friday
morning to do stuff um
but we'll see we're hoping uh we're
gonna reach out to people maybe we can
get
i don't think they'd give us any more
than one episode since there's only
going to be six of them
so we might see the first episode but um
that will only mean that you know the
breakdown
uh comes out a little bit earlier on
friday or saturday
uh than it would have otherwise but
that's it as of this taping no we
haven't seen anything in advance would
that be cool
yeah what if zemo sent hayward to sword
to get information on ai
and cybernetics to start a sentinel
program
to fight against the supers mmm i like
how you're thinking my friend
i love that because i like no one trusts
hayward
like hey like i'm very upset that like
well i'm not very upset i'm like i'm
okay with it
that hayward was just some guy some just
some
jerk guy just deserved to get hit by
a a van or a funnel cake truck
because i've always contended since the
beginning as soon as i saw hayward
i was like that man there's something
about that man
and i did this weird thing where i just
started um looking up anagrams of his
name because i was like
you can't spell hayward without hydra
hydra is in
hayward's last name so i was like you
know what what if his name is something
hydra
i spent many hours on that nothing
happened with that uh
i wasted my time we should have been
talking to girls instead but i was not
girls don't talk to me um a lot of
things were just said
anyway yes um that's a really good idea
yeah i think uh i don't know if uh zemo
would have
sent hayward because hayward was before
all this was just
us an agent of sword he was just like a
company man
i don't think he would be like okay i'll
listen to you accused
international terrorist zemo but they
could have been part of the same plot
they could have been drinking from the
same kool-aid
uh the idea of it being to build a
sentinels program
i love the idea of sentinels because it
seems thematically
kind of what hayward was doing right
he's trying to build his own sentient
weapons and that is kind of what the
sentinels are it
does seem kind of what project cataract
was all about
i just think again it's going to be a
little too soon if
i don't think sentinels would be our way
into mutants
in the mcu i could be totally wrong
about that i just i think
sentinels is kind of something that's
part of the world of the x-men and the
mutants
and i think you need what's the most
exciting way to introduce mutants in the
mcu
probably through the eyes of one of
those characters um
and that's why i think uh you know it's
gonna be
one person or it's gonna be like the
history of their genetic history
uh to imply that they were around us the
whole time i think it's kind of exciting
but to say like the thing that was used
to kill the mutants
is going to be the way we learn about
the existence of mutants in the mcu
it just feels like kind of uh you know
four steps removed just start with that
first step
would be my approach personally one last
question and it is from
rainbow roy so do you think that
the reason the government is giving the
title of captain america to john walker
is because sam wilson did not sign the
sokovia accords
yes that's going to be the reason they
say but the real reasons racism
i think right that's that's likely
racism it's just like you were
you were on the run you have a criminal
past sir we can't sell that
give us that shield the fact that
they're still they would still be mad
about the sokovia accords after end game
it's like
dudes the avengers helped save this
planet everyone who's on that
battlefield deserves a medal of honor
and they deserve to have whatever
criminal record they had wiped clean
so if the sokovia accords still matter
in a post-in-game world
then that's going to tell you something
about their real motives it would mean
that you know sam wilson doesn't
meet up the proper criteria for who they
want captain america to be
to the american public so i think race
would be
a pretty big motivator and if malcolm
spellman is writing this series i
would imagine he would have something to
say about it i mean yeah i mean if if
bucky's walking around free and like
there's nothing
like he's just like all right bucky's
just like walking amongst the people
and like cat and sam can't get the
shield that's some shenanigans that's
that's not cool well bucky would
probably be i mean they might say well
we also would deny it to bucky
um it's like well cap himself gave me
this shield
like that was i was his chosen uh
successor
uh yeah i uh i i we'll see how they end
up playing it i would imagine
sokovia chords is gonna be the reason
they give just because the end game
screenwriters said yeah the soviet
accords still matter when they did an
endgame watch along
um so i think it's gonna they're gonna
claim it's important
uh there's gonna be a lot of interesting
subjects that are brought up on this
show i'm
very excited to see that kind of
approach that they take yeah i think
you're right on the money i think
they're
they are going to use that excuse and
it's probably just going to be just like
all right
we just you just don't have the right
skin color i'm sorry buddy you don't
look like steve
they look like steve urkel wow that was
really bad
well uh so that is a wrap for this q a
uh thank you so much to everyone
sticking with us on stereo mt
and i are going to be reacting to every
episode of the falcon winter soldier
every friday and well we're going to try
to do some q and a's with you guys as
well
just to answer all the questions you
have about this show um but we did this
on stereo thanks again to all of our
stereo listeners you can download stereo
by going to
stereo.com new rockstars and you'll
subscribe to us as well you'll be able
to uh see when all of our
weekly or not weekly we do them pretty
much every day of the week when all the
shows go live
you'll be you'll be there for it and
you'll be able to send us your questions
we'll
respond to you in real time it's very
exciting um
but be sure to follow mt mastertainment
and follow me
at eavos uh follow a new rockstar
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast
uh thank you so much for watching
watching it's the watching
[Laughter]
i'm an idiot um but i thank you all
and i will see you next time as always
we're on your left
[Music]
you